Alright guys, so here is the last example. You can see the Asian session ended here. We have our BUI right here. So I wait for price to come back into a BUI, which happens right here. I drop down to one minute. And I look for my market structure shift. It happens just right here. I would take my entry from actually, I would take my entry from this level because they are
very close to each other. And also if I drag this along, you might remember my auto block,
fake out auto block, liquidy trading strategy. So you see we had a small little change of
victory here. And you can see price went down and now it's pushed back up again. Now this
This old auto block has BPR.
This auto block.
So this is like the best area for me to enter off of.
So I would take my entry here, put my stop probably right here.
Just below the body right here.
And I would target probably this level right here.
I'm not sure.
But let's see how this plays out.
So we get a beautiful entry right here and price did it hit on take profit it did not
it just simply reacted off this fair value gap so in a normal condition I would look for
one to two but this was this could have been 2.5 easily but if you probably held yep
so actually it just went ahead and took out this take profit level and I believe it takes
I have the Asian high as well, okay, I don't think so.
I'm not sure.
Let's see, let's see.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Go up, go up, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, no.
No, no, okay, nevermind.
So yeah, this would have been actually, one to three residual trade guys.
It's really simple, um, mechanical,
technical to an strategy that you can use.
I hope you guys enjoyed and took some knowledge
off of this course update.
As I said before, there are gonna be a lot of course updates
in the future and you're gonna get that for absolutely free.
I'm just gonna keep on updating the course,
uploading more videos because Ist content is too big
and even if I spend like a week constantly making videos
again and again it's not gonna be enough so I need time so I'll try to
upload more videos after each month I would say but anyways if you have any
questions let me know and I'll answer them and goodbye take care love you guys